– Und? Wie fandest du die Ausstellung?
– Es geht. Das Stadtschloss war
beeindruckend,
aber die Ausstellung war
relativ uninteressant.
– Du bist kaum vier Stunden hier
und es ist wie früher,
als wir noch in der Ausbildung waren.
– Stimmt!
– Wie lange bleibst du eigentlich?
– Nicht lange.
Ich reise gerade herum und dachte, ich
komme dich besuchen und sage kurz Hallo.
– Schön, dass es dir wieder besser geht.
– Ich vermisse meinen Vater sehr, Yara.
Aber ... er wollte immer, dass ich die Welt
sehe, und jetzt … mach ich es.
Danke für die letzten Wochen.
Ich bin so froh, dass du da warst.
Was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
– Es gibt hier ein kleines Museum,
das dir bestimmt gut gefällt.
Ein bekannter Komponist aus dieser
Stadt hat dort gelebt.
Er schrieb viele Stücke
für Geige und Klavier
und, er ist vor ’n paar
Jahren gestorben.
Ich war noch nie da.
Sollen wir uns das mal anschauen?
– Ja, okay.